this is the last of the word problems
that courtesan sent and they're all
interesting because they're all
involving distances and rates and times
and they all involve you doing having to
do a little bit of implicit algebra
without having to explicitly solve for
values of variables and that's why
they're fun so this one says N and Betty
two cyclists start simultaneously and at
Point a and at Point a and Betty at
point B Betty at point B they travel to
each other at constant speeds so let's
say that n is traveling with velocity a
and Betty is traveling with velocity B
constant speeds they pass each other in
30 minutes okay so they're going to pass
each other someplace in between a and B
I'll just arbitrarily draw that they're
going to pass each other there and what
are these distances it took them 30
minutes to both get this point right
they pass each other in 30 minutes and
aunt and Ann headed for point B arrives
there in another 20 minutes okay so this
distance takes n 30 minutes so this is
so what's the actual distance so it's
always useful to write distance is equal
to rate times time so what's the actual
distance she traveled well the rate is
VA she traveled a rate of VA and her
time they tell us it took her 30 30
minutes to get there so VA times 30
let's say this velocity is expressed in
minutes fair enough and then and then
headed for point B arrives there another
20 minutes so this is going to take her
another 20 minutes so this distance
right here is what it's she's going at
the same velocity but it takes her 20
minutes so the distance is velocity
times time so it's VA times 20 or 20 VA
fair enough how many minutes after an
Horizon point B will Betty arrive at
Point a so Betty was going in this
direction they meet right here and then
she keeps going in hits point a so the
key realization here is that this took
an 30 minutes to get here but it also
took Betty 30 minutes to
so what's this distance in terms of
Betty's velocity what's this distance
well distance is equal to rate times
time it took Betty 30 minutes to go this
distance at a velocity of VB so it took
her 30 V be meters or whatever actually
we don't even have to specify the units
whatever the unit's the velocities in if
it's in meters per minute then this is
the distance in meters it takes her this
distance is 30 VB right so essentially
we just have to figure out what how long
it takes her to travel this remaining
distance and we would have solved the
problem so how can we do that well we
can already set up a relationship
between VB and VA because this distance
is the same it doesn't matter how fast
you travel it the distance doesn't
change so we know that 30 times
Betty's velocity is equal to 20 times
and velocity 20 VA and so if we wanted
to express and velocity in terms of
Betty's velocity let's do it just do it
that way we get let me scroll down a
little bit if we divide both sides by 20
we get three halfs three halfs
of Betty's velocity is equal to Ann's
velocity fair enough so what is this
distance in terms of Betty's velocity we
know it in terms of Ann's velocity in
terms of Ann's velocity it's 30 it's 30
times and velocity right so what is 30
times NS velocity in terms of Betty's
velocity well if we multiply this times
30 that's 30 times and philosophy so we
can multiply both sides of this times 30
so if you multiply 30 times here and
times 30 this is the distance this
distance right here Ann's velocity times
30 minutes took her 30 minutes to travel
that far so this is the same distance
expressed in Betty's velocity so to see
30 times 3 is 90 divided by 2 is 45 so
it's 45 VB so this distance up here is
45 VB
so distance is equal to rate times so
this is rate times time so this is how
many minutes it took Betty to travel
this distance so what is the question
asking us how many minutes after Ann
reaches at point B will Betty arrive at
Point a so they both reach right here in
another 20 minutes and gets here and how
many minutes in another 45 minutes Betty
will get over there another 45 minutes
so it takes n 20 minutes to get here
takes Betty 45 minutes to go get here
after their meeting right at the center
so it's going to take Betty another 25
minutes right after 20 minutes Ann is
here in the way after wait another 25
minutes for Betty to get here 45 minutes
after this meeting so the answer is 25
minutes 25 minutes
how many minutes after Ann arrives at
point B will Betty arrive at Point a yep
25 minutes they could have just asked
how many minutes after the meeting will
it take Betty to reach point 8 would
have been 45 but they want to know how
many more minutes after and gets there
anyway thought you would find that
useful and final time thanks for thanks
to cartoccio for sending that problem